hi everyone sal here from khan academy
uh as i'm sure you're aware we are
finding ourselves collectively our
planet in a very interesting situation
right now and a lot of unfortunate
things are happening and one of those
unfortunate things is the potential for
school closures and so all of us here at
khan academy we've essentially stopped
what we're doing and review it as our
duty to be able to support you through
this to help you help ensure that
students continue to learn
i know a lot of districts are facing a
lot of
difficult decisions to make thinking
about whether to close whether to
virtualize there's a lot of equity
issues at stake who has access to
internet and computers at home there's
other things around child care free and
reduced lunch but we're going to try to
do our part to support everyone as much
as possible
big picture if you have younger kids if
you're a parent and you have younger
kids at home early elementary or even
pre-k
i think the key is to focus on the
basics even if students are able to put
in a solid two hours of learning per day
that will at least keep them on track i
would focus on
reading so that could be if they if they
aren't able to read on their own yet
reading with them we're going to be
sending out reading lists uh different
activities you could do with your
students
and some form of mathematics we have
khan academy kids free app
non-commercial anyone can download it
and that has over 100 books available
that you could read with your child it
will also read to your child we think
the best use case of khan academy kids
is maybe in sessions of about 20 minutes
ideally with your child's next to an
adult you or an older sibling and that
covers not just pre-k through first
grade standards math but it also covers
reading
writing and social emotional learning on
top of that if your student has time to
do some handwriting practice we think
that is great or some type of journaling
if they are already at that level as we
get into later elementary middle school
khan academy math we think can be really
valuable for them help them stay on
track you can start them at their grade
level we're oftentimes seeing a lot of
success if kids start well before grade
level and then are able to
master their way all the way through
grade level
i would recommend also for the older
elementary the middle school students to
have at least an hour of day of reading
that could be broken up into the two
30-minute sessions if if needed
once again we're going to try to provide
some reading lists and things like that
as you get into middle school early high
school and high school we have even more
resources for students
on top of what i just talked about about
the mathematics which we have that go it
goes from pre-k all the way through
early college
we can help those students with
enrichment things like computer
programming we'll also provide reading
lists for them
also in the sciences i think
students as early as as middle school
and definitely in high school obviously
biology is of interest today
glass half full that could be a learning
opportunity learn about viruses learning
how disease spreads learn about
exponential growth
i think a lot of students at the middle
school and high school level could begin
to engage in our high school level
biology or even some of our high school
level chemistry as you get into uh the
core of high school above and beyond
those things we have high school level
physics we have economics micro
macroeconomics american history
civics and government
at both the high school level and the
advanced placement early college level
and on top of that we have official sat
practice so if you if you're an older
student i would recommend you could
structure your day even longer we're
going to be giving out some schedules
that you could work from
so that you can stay on track to be
prepared to get college ready and make
sure that you don't have any lost
learning
so we'll be sending out more uh details
uh more videos more information as we
learn more uh but
we are doing everything we can to make
sure that we can we can have you covered
it's our duty as a not-for-profit with
the mission of free world-class
education for anyone anywhere
to to support you in this very
challenging time